voilà le rayonnement et l'influencé
considérable de simone de beauvoir que
reste-t-il aujourd'hui de son oeuvre de
ces combats de ses idées elle avait on
l'a vu ces contradictions intérieures sa
part d' aveuglement aussi notamment sur
la politique que faut-il en comprendre
et puis le féminisme a beaucoup changé
depuis simone de beauvoir à ce qu'elle
se reconnaîtrait dans celle qui
aujourd'hui ont repris le flambeau ce
sont quelques-unes des nombreuses
questions avec lesquels nous laisse ce
film beauvoir laventure d'être soit
signée fabrice gardel et mathieu
weschler et pour approfondir à présent
j'accueille sur ce plateau elisabeth
philippe bonjour bonjour cette
journaliste à l'ops notre partenaire sur
cette émission bonjour avoue françois
speak
je vous êtes docteur en sciences
politiques spécialiste de l'histoire du
féminisme
vous avez enseigné à l'université paris
dauphine et je précise que vous avez
croisé la route de simone de beauvoir
vous nous en direz plus bonjour michel
caille
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
professeur de philosophie ancien membre
du comité de rédaction des temps
modernes est avec nous également à
distance peggy sastre bonjour bonjour
journaliste et essayiste à l'ordre toute
première question une première réaction
elizabeth phillips portrait de simone de
beauvoir on se dit c'était une femme de
son temps peut-être même toujours en
avance sur son temps oui ça très
certainement très en avance sur son
temps parce que j'ai particulièrement
apprécié dans ce documentaire c'est que
simone de beauvoir n'est pas
immédiatement présentée par rapport à
sartre ce qui a longtemps été le cas et
sartre danse dans ce film arrive
relativement tardivement puisque on se
souvient d'ailleurs s'est précisée dans
le film on la surnommait la grande
chartreuse notre-dame de sartre a été
continuellement présenté dans l'ombre de
sa voir considérer comme sont inférieurs
notamment sur le plan philosophique et
là je pense qu'on le rapport là est en
train de s'inverser en tout cas on
rêvait réévaluent complètement l'oeuvre
de simone de beauvoir et saas et ses
enfants que j'ai particulièrement
apprécié dans le documentaire
même françois si vous êtes d'accord
simone de beauvoir à sa juste place dans
ce film oui puisque c'est un film qui
est qui est centrée sur elle sur la
question que vous posiez en avance sur
son temps c'est clair
le deuxième sexe est paru en 49 et c'est
resté
même si ça eu un succès très important
c'est quand même restée sans effets
politiques et il a fallu quand même une
génération après pour que le mouvement
féministe des années 60 et 70 soit le
prolongement dans les faits de la pensée
timone des pouvoirs alors on va avoir
l'occasion de vraiment de parler de ce
livre le 2e siècle qui est de le 2e
siècle ce qui est effectivement qui a eu
une influence considérable michel cas il
peut être ce qui est intéressant dans ce
film c'est le fait qu'on se rend compte
qu'elle a non seulement changé la vie
des femmes mais eux mais surtout
peut-être le les rapports les relations
entre les hommes et les femmes
oui certainement et je voudrais dire mon
accord avec ce que disait il les avait
séparé très important de réévaluer la
relation sartre beauvoir et notamment
alors bon c'est un peu une
spécialisation professionnelle mais
notamment sur le plan philosophique et
c'est en fonction de ces engagements et
de ses partis pris philosophique qu'elle
a pu aider à changer les relations entre
les hommes et les femmes pays sastre un
mode réaction sur ce que nous venons de
voir sur ce film une beau voir au fond
révolutionnaire révolutionnaire oui mais
je dirais un très bon sens du terme
parce que une deux une des choses qui
m'a qui m'a frappé dans effectivement ce
film ce film est très bon ramant à mon
avis c'est une personne qui en fait noyé
dans son idéologie
c'est d'ailleurs très intéressant un
moment il ya un petit parallèle avec son
éducation religieuse
j'ai beaucoup apprécié donc voilà ce qui
m'a ce que je retiendrai de ce
documentaire c'est sa cohérence ce
qu'elles soient persuadés comme ça de
très contrasté son aveuglement politique
elle a quand même pas suis senti en
asile est là encore - là encore moins su
sentir le communisme comme si elle était
en fait tellement centré sur
l'oppression des femmes que les deux
plus grosses idéologie n'est plus
oppressive du xxème siècle elle est
loupé et donc ça c'est très très
important fonds alors tout ça on va
vraiment avoir l'occasion de dalé un
d'approfondir ces sujets là parce
qu'effectivement incohérences
contradictions d'où est ce que ça vient
on va en parler mais il ya quelque chose
qui m'a frappé dans le film est est ce
que je trouve très
intéressant c'est que les virements par
son envergure intellectuelle mais elle
parle de choses très concrètes
elle parle de choses voilà elle parle de
la vie des femmes et notamment de ces
femmes qui lui écrivent
oui bah c'est pas pour rien que c'est
elle se rattache à la philosophie
existentialiste donc tout part de la vie
de l'existence et une récente biographie
que lui a consacré une autre e-street
annick je crois que s'appelle quelques
clics patrick bardon montre à quel point
finalement la vie fait ce qui ce qui
fait que beauvoir continue d'inspirer
des gens et d'être une référence et
autant son oeuvre que sa vie qui était
vraiment une philosophie en acte et je
pense que c'est ça aussi qui permet qui
rend un peu son sa pensée accessible
c'est qu'elle en ait elle-même
l'incarnation l'incarnation de cette
émancipation de cette liberté elle
prouve en acte que c'est possible de
faire sauter les carcans de l'oppression
de la domination masculine de
l'oppression patriarcale
c'est ce qui en fait qu'elle est
accessible mais aussi crédible et
légitime certainement certainement mais
il faut qu'on parle maintenant quand
même de ce livre dont il est beaucoup
question dans le dans le film le
deuxième sexe qui sort en 1949 là-dessus
michel caye j'aurais vous grandissiez
sur ce que disait tout à l'heure
françois speak il a fallu du temps
beaucoup de temps peut-être une
génération de génération pour que ce
livre infuse vraiment dans la société
française oui sauf quand même pas il ya
quand même un accueil immédiat c mais il
semble très important c'est que yann
c'est vraiment un grand livre
philosophique je crois qu'ils assistent
les six rôles et philosophique et il ya
à ce moment là vous voyez dans le la
moitié du 20e siècle il y a quatre
grands livres il ya l'être et le néant
de sartre il ya la phénoménologie de la
perception de merleau ponty et il ya les
structures élémentaires de la parenté de
lévi strauss est à côté de ces problèmes
il ya celui de beauvoir et elle maîtrise
les trois les trois autres et alors ce
qui est quand même très important c'est
que quel est le louvre âge philosophique
qui a eu une telle influence parce qu'à
la fois c'est in un ouvrage de grande
qualité philosophique et qui va avoir
une influence comme il était dit
dans l'existence de nombreuses femmes ça
c'est ça me semble très important de
souligner c'est intéressant ce que vous
dites parce qu'on a on a tendance à
considérer
voilà vu d'aujourd'hui en 2021 que c'est
un livre militant mais c'est d'abord
selon vous voilà un livre de philosophie
y sommes absolument oui
et le parti pris pour aller très vite
c'est le parti pris de lentilles
naturalisme et moi je préfère d'ailleurs
dire le la naturalisme c'est à dire le a
privatif parce que en fait c'est ce
point de départ la qui permet à la fois
la rencontre avec les lectrices c'est
extraordinaire cette rencontre c'est à
dire que tout d'un coup voyez c'est un
pavé et il ya les lectrices qui se
reconnaissent qu'ils se l'approprient
qui vont faire ensuite le moyen d'un
engagement collectif
alors il y à il ya 7 oui pardon je
disais c'est parce que nous et on a
tendance à le considérer comme un livre
militant mais voilà est-ce que elle le
considérait comme ça à françois c'était
pas du tout pas du tout quand on lit le
deuxième sexe il est très clair que
simone de beauvoir ne se reconnaît pas
comme féministe à ce moment là au
contraire puisqu'elle considère quand
elle parle elle a une assez bonne
connaissance de l'histoire du féminisme
mais en même temps elle dit il se
reconnaît pas dans la filiation elle
considère que le mouvement fait mieux
que le féminisme n'a jamais constitué un
mouvement autonome et elle pense pas que
ça soit jamais le cas elle est là des
comparaisons assure sur les femmes n'ont
jamais formé un collectif comme comme
les les ouvriers des usines
les juifs des ghettos les noirs des
plantations etc
elles sont dispersés parmi les hommes
donc elle à elle a une vision
effectivement philosophique et dans
laquelle le féminisme elle dit le
féminisme a fait couler beaucoup d'encre
c'est terminé n'en parlons plus mais on
en parle encore aujourd'hui et voilà et
donc après elle reprend dans cette
introduction du deuxième sexe on a
l'impression qu'elle pense qu'elle clôt
une histoire qui est terminée et elle ne
réalise pas à quel point l on ouvre une
nouvelle d'ailleurs c'est ce que dit
l'événement d'amateurs dans le film elle
dit elle ouvre les portes de la prison
avec ce livre absolument oui mais c'est
vrai que c'est amusant de relire
l'introduction du deuxième sexe
aujourd'hui puisqu'elle commence par
cette phrase je crois en disant que la
querelle du féministe différence mais
klose
donc c'est assez amusant quand on voit à
quel point ce livre effectivement est
une matrice en fait pour pour le
féminisme à venir et le féminisme
contemporain et pour toute la société
là-dessus peggy sastre j'aimerais bien
vous entendre parce qu'on a l'impression
que ce combat de voie ouverte par simone
de beauvoir
il est en quelque sorte aujourd'hui
n'ont pas terminé mais gagner au moins
dans les sphères on va dire de des
décisions les sphères politiques les
sphères d'influencé est ce que c'est
votre sentiment ou pas et je dirais que
les grands les grands combats et ont été
gagnés et un détail à intéressant qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas souvent rappelés
chez simone de beauvoir et notamment
dans le film c'est qu'elle est tout l
est toutes un même un chapitre de son
livre c'est le chapitre 8 de la deuxième
partie du tome 2 du deuxième sexe dès
qu'elles consacrent prostituées et et
haïr et qui à mon sens est l'un des
passages les en fait les moins date et
les mois d'été de 2 to sont de tout son
livre était justement ces femmes
émancipées par l'argent parce qu'il ya
tout qui alliait tous ces développements
chez elle qui aussi là aussi reste
beaucoup tout à fait d'actualité qui et
quand on à l'indépendance financière on
a à peu près on a on est à peu près tout
gagné au niveau haut niveau féminin au
niveau féministe et justement pour
reprendre le fil de la de la
conversation ce qui reste aujourd'hui à
mon sens à gagner qui n'est justement
pas gagné
c'est toute la question de la
prostitution les droits des postures des
droits des prostituées qui aidera donc
c'est ça ça que je suis redevable à
simone de beauvoir de l'avoir de l'avoir
mis en lumière alors que justement
aujourd'hui et même les mêmes elle-même
à l'époque on a on a on avait on avait
tendance à palm être papa mettre en
avant est juste un dernier point que
j'étais beaucoup gdt beaucoup frappé
dans dans le documentaire en fait à la
réception du deuxième sexe comment elle
se fait chambrer
parce que justement on dit qu'elle parle
de choses des règles voilà tout le monde
connaît tout le monde connaît le vagin
de simone de beauvoir et serra est en
fait moi ça m'a beaucoup ça m'a beaucoup
fait penser un autre grand livre du du
début du xxième sexe et du 20e siècle
pardon qui est la section qui est
la vie sexuelle de catherine m par
catherine millet et la réception des des
deux livres sont très très comparable
parce que voilà le maroc pourra pas en
parler mais la musique c'est le
quatrième pour moi c'est un très grand
livre est pareil à cfi chambrer par ses
phares ses compagnons de route etc en
disant oui c'est trop prosaïque etc
c'est le parallèle le trouvais très très
il y aurait beaucoup de choses à dire
notamment sur effectivement la question
du privé qui devient en quelque sorte
publique et politique
quand même cette question qui vous
faisait réagir tout à l'heure ce combat
timone de vaud voir notamment celui
qu'elle présente dans le iième siècle
sexe est-il gagner ou pas selon vous il
est évident que depuis 49 et la
publication du deuxième sexe là la
condition des femmes s'est grandement
améliorée et qu'il ya beaucoup de
deux combats qui ont été gagnés et de
choses qui ont qui ont changé plutôt en
mieux et c'est heureux évidemment après
dans ce qui constitue la structure et le
coeur même de la pensée de beauvoir
développer dans le deuxième sexe moi je
pense qu'il ya des éléments qui sont pas
encore entendus et compris et notamment
une des grandes thèses de ce livre c'est
que elle veut lutter contre cette idée
qui en fait au coeur de la domination
masculine qui est que l'homme a toujours
été présenté comme le nil universelle et
la femme comme l'autre et je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez de cette phrase
prononcée par emmanuel macron pendant la
campagne présidentielle où il disait je
suis profondément féministe car je crois
en l'altérité et l'autre de l'homme
c'est la femme
donc là on peut dire que par exemple
d'entreprise je pense que ce débat il
est fondamental il fait partie des
débats majeurs en ce moment quand on
parle de l'universel de la neutralité
enfin ce sont vraiment des débats qui
sont encore extrêmement actuelle un mot
rapide sur ce sujet là françoise oui je
pense que il quand elle dit le combat en
gros nous avons gagné la partie
alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
les revendications des féministes ce
qu'on appelle la première vague c'était
l'égalité des droits
c'est à qui s'est inscrit dans la
constitution etc
mais le problème c'est comment ça va
passer dans la réalité est là elle a
cette phrase par rapport à l'égalité qui
est qui est tout à fait elle change
complètement la conception qu'on peut
avoir de l'égalité elle dit elle
commence par reconnaître le fait que les
hommes et les femmes qui ne sont pas
égaux c'est à dire que il faut
s'entendre sur ce qu'on entend par el
para pareil elle de lloris
quand elle dit quand un individu ou un
groupe d'individus est maintenue en
situation d'infériorité
le fait est qu'il est un fait qu'il est
inégale et c'est ça qu'il faut changer
donc cette exigence la de changer la
caisse que ce qu'est ce que c'est que
l'égalité est d'en faire donc
donc ce combat là celui là il est pas
gagné mais il faut le fait de l'avoir
posée c'est déjà une étape extrêmement
importante
dernière question sur ce livre michel
caye puisque ces dix par l'un des
interlocuteurs qu'on ait entendu dans le
film françois noudelmann
vous iriez vous aussi que c'est un livre
pour les hommes
le deuxième sexe c'est aussi six à lire
et c'est plein d'enseignements pour les
hommes et moi je pense évidemment je
suis pas très bien placé pour le dire
mais je pense que le combat est loin
d'être gagné notamment parce que disons
que d'être le mouvement des femmes le
mouvement féministe relâche la pression
il y à un retour de bâton et ça ça veut
dire qu' il est difficile d'inscrire le
thème de l'égalité d'autant plus que
réclamer les mêmes droits que les hommes
c'est s'inscrire dans le système
patriarcal donc en fait il faut
redéfinir
l'égalité c'est pour ça que cette
redéfinition d'égalité elle se fera si
les hommes acceptent aussi de d'entrer
dans un autre type de relation je
rappelle d'ailleurs la phrase qui
évoquait tout à l'heure peggy sastre et
qui est cité dans le film cette phrase
très célèbre n'oubliez jamais qu'il
suffira d'une crise politique économique
ou religieuse pour que les droits des
femmes soient remis en question c'est
une phrase que beauvoir prononce
d'ailleurs lorsqu'elle va aux états unis
s'est rappelée dans le film est
d'ailleurs ça nous amène à un point que
je voudrais évoquer avec vous qui voit
la simone de beauvoir la femme n'ont pas
l'intellectuel mais voilà la femme
parfois passionnés est vrai qu'on
s'arrête sur un des moments qui est très
touchant très émouvant et parfois est un
peu déconcertant dans le film c'est cet
épisode de sa vie où elle tombe
éperdument amoureuse amoureuse de
l'écrivain américain nelson algren et je
voudrais qu'on en parle parce que ce
n'est pas anecdotique regardez c'est les
la naissance de l'amour fou on découvre
une simone de beauvoir presque
midinettes elle elle montre un autre
aspect de sa féminité et peut-être de
ses désirs qui n'étaient pas satisfaits
à paris ils s'écriront des lettres
brûlante
[Musique]
on a beaucoup glosé sur le fait que dans
sa correspondance avec nelson
elle lui dit j'aimerais être ta petite
femme d'intérieur et je suis toute
petite grenouille d'amour et c'est un
truc un peu minaudant on dit ah bah vous
voyez la grogne féministes etc
il voudrait être près de lui pour lui
faire la cuisine pour les blanchir son
l'âge qu'elle peut plus se passer de lui
que c'est un manque terrible qu'elle
pleure voilà là on a vraiment besoin de
comprendre parce que j'aimerais être ta
petite femme d'intérieur il ya
manifestement une contradiction avec le
discours absolument révolutionnaire dont
on parlait à l'instant
écoutez je ne sais pas ce que ce que
j'ai lu même des de l' échange de
lettres entre simone de beauvoir et
nelson algren et 2 que ce qui se passait
quand elle était là-bas elle ne faisait
pas du tout la cuisine elle faisait pas
du tout le ménage et elle était furieuse
parce que le chat lui les griffer sebha
elle s'est jamais comporté effectivement
de cette façon là elle a pratiquement je
sais pas comment alors on parle de
nelson algren on pourrait parler aussi
de d'un autre amour contingent comme
comme disait le pacte mais qui quand
même a eu beaucoup d'importance dans la
dans la vie de simone de beauvoir cesser
sa relation avec claude lanzmann avec
qui elle a vécu quand même huit ou neuf
ans et elle a vécu avec lui alors
qu'elle n'a jamais vécu avec start et je
pense pas qu'elle lui jamais fait la
cuisine non plus chez simone de beauvoir
enfin je manger au restaurant de façon
permanente je sais tu pas et elle l
avait vraiment décidé que ce que ça
faisait pas partie de son univers
en revanche la la la la relation avec
nelson algren qui est une relation
passionnelle était certainement une
relation physique de beaucoup plus
importante que que la relation
permanente et éternelle est importante
et fondamentale avec sartre et voilà sur
cette contradiction apparente comme le
fait remarquer institut le coq dans le
documentaire
quand on est seul grain demande à ses
monaco voire de venir vivre avec lui aux
etats-unis elle refuse ce qui passe
devant ce qui passe avant tout c'est le
travail parce que serbes ont peu on peut
voir une contradiction mais quand même
ce qui est la ligne rouge du le fil
rouge de la vie de simone de beauvoir
c'est le travail moi c'est ça qui me
subjugue qui me fascine dans sa vie
c'est cette force considérable de
travail
cette force de la volonté et ce qui est
intéressant dans la biographie dont je
parlais tout à l'heure de kate kick
patrick c'est que il ya quand même une
distinction entre les mémoires de simone
de beauvoir ou finalement elle accorde
une place très peu importante à nelson
algren
et puis là les correspondances qui
laisse comprendre que la relation était
bien plus passionnelle que ce qu'elle en
dit dans ses mémoires et et la biographe
quelques clics patrick pardon avant
cette hypothèse c'est que pour rendre
son scandale ça plus plus comment dire
tolérable par les lecteurs de l'époque
simone de beauvoir a consciemment
minimiser ses relations extra-conjugales
entre guillemets enfin lors du pacte
pour que ça soit plus acceptable pour
montrer qu'elle était la femme d'un seul
homme sarthe
je voudrais qu'on qu'on parle aussi d'un
autre aspect qui est évoqué dans le
documentaire et vous vous avez dit un
mot peggy sastre on peut on peut avancer
un peu plus en profondeur sur son
aveuglement sur sur le stalinisme sur
sur mao aussi d'où vient selon vous
peggy sastre cet aveuglement qui
effectivement rétrospectivement on peut
paraître extrêmement choquant avant de
jeter un juste points pointe et 1 1
point qui m'a hakima qui m'a beaucoup
intéressé dans dans le documentaire
justement avec un grain c'est son
changement qui dit qu'elle est là elle
est enrobé les enjeux aller après
évidemment c'est sans doute à une
sélection du documentaire que c'est
haram et c'est vraiment c'est c'est
quelque chose que je voulais souligner
wissant son aveuglement
on apprend que le mans et idéologiques
et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs c'est bien
de faire le lien avec la relation d
kalck rennes parce que vous si le
passage où on parle de sa relation avec
les graines c'est un passage où à mon
sens elle devient end elle devient une
menace à la salle et le phénomène avant
un an
je vous aime justement elle a une
épaisseur qui n'est pas seulement
idéologie c'est intéressant ça parce que
effectivement quand on le canton
la voix dans le film par moments on se
dit voilà il ya quelque chose
d'idéalistes chez elle voit d'idéologues
qui exploite ya un truc en soldat pas il
ya vraiment un
à la limite du fanatisme du dogmatisme
et c'est ça aussi je reviens à ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est c'est très
intéressant le lien qui est fait dans le
documentaire entre eux elle a pris son
éducation religieuse elle est à la
plaque mixa sur la politique et les plus
hautes et très manichéen il ya les
gentils et les méchants mais c'est
quelque chose en fait qui ce qui
s'observe chez c'est plein de
personnalités qui se trouvait là très
idéologique de cette génération
notamment et c'est intéressant ce michel
caye peut-être un mot là-dessus parce
que dans le documentaire il est dit que
c'est sa haine de la société bourgeoise
qui fait que le couple
pour le coup le couple beauvoir sartre
choisi son camp c'est le fameux tout
anti communiste est un est un chien vous
diriez que cette haine de la bourgeoisie
a contribué à l'aveuglé michel caye ça
ça certainement se sait
disons que ça c'est une position de
départ et c'est ce qui va lui permettre
aussi toute cette évolution sur
l'engagement politique j'aimerais dire
juste une petite chose c'est que en fait
il ya une rupture aussi bien pour sartre
d'ailleurs que pour eux boire c'est mai
68 c'est à dire que précédemment ils
sont sollicités et surtout sartre
d'ailleurs à ce moment là à vouloir
reste un peu en retrait ils sont
sollicités en tant qu'intellectuel et on
leur demande finalement d'intervenir
dans un champ politique est déjà
entièrement défini alors que à partir de
68 c'est là où l'évolution de beauvoir
va être très importante c'est parce que
et celle aussi de sartre c'est à dire
qu'ils vont devenir réellement le disons
des militants c'est à dire que là ils
vont vraiment s'engager
sartre dents du côté maoïstes et j mal
de voir des côtes et féministe est alors
chez elle c'est une rupture importante
parce que la fin du deuxième set s'est
confié l'émancipation des femmes à la
révolution socialiste
alors que ensuite il n'en est plus
question l'émancipation des femmes sera
l'oeuvre comme disait l'autre des femmes
elles-mêmes voyez c'est à dire que tout
d'un coup elle dit il n'ya qu'un seul
féminisme c'est le féminisme radical et
se féminise le radical a pour condition
l'autonomie de la lutte des femmes
alors là vous m'offrez une transition
toute trouvée avec le sujet qui va nous
occuper jusqu'à la fin de cette émission
l'héritage l'héritage aujourd'hui de
simone de beauvoir parce que je le
disais en présentant cette émission on
est face à un paysage féministes qui est
bouleversée évidemment depuis maintenant
plusieurs décennies mais
particulièrement ces dernières années
des femmes qui se divise sur la cause
des femmes
comment elisabeth philippe il vient
c'est difficile de faire parler les
morts mais comment est ce que simone de
beauvoir voilà contemplerait ce paysage
aujourd'hui selon alors déjà le
féminisme a toujours été divisés ya
toujours eu des féministes messahel elle
le rappeler
vraiment il ya une interview que j'ai
relu récemment quand j'ai préparé le
dossier de loeb sur les manifs et des
343 dans lequel simone de beauvoir a
joué un rôle extrêmement important un
rôle central c'est une interview de 1972
qu'elle a donné à la journaliste
allemande alice schwarzer donc dans le
nouvel observateur à l'époque et elle
explique effectivement ce que ce que ce
qu'a dit michel keil que le mai 68 a
vraiment constitué une rupture et dans
son engagement féministe qu'elle ne
l'était pas avant et qu'elle est devenue
donc c'est quand même assez assez
intéressant de ce point de vue là
ensuite vous me posiez la question de
son de son héritage
quelqu'un comme virginie despentes par
exemple qu'on peut voir comme
l'incarnation aujourd'hui du féminisme
contemporain la cites dans king kong
théorie elle reprend notamment la phrase
du deuxième siècle dans laquelle simone
de beauvoir dit que le vrai féminin est
un produit une production artificielle
donc elle elle est reprise et énormément
de livres qui paraissent écrit par des
jeunes auteurs et autres hisse donc je
pense qu'elle elle reste une figure très
importante pour le féminisme
contemporain ensuite ou est ce qu'elle
se situerait moi j'avais fait une
interview de son de sa fille adoptive
sylvie le bon
de beauvoir il ya quelques temps et
encore une fois c'est difficile de faire
parler les morts mais sylvie le bond de
bouvard me disait elle aurait été simone
de beauvoir aurait été du côté de mitu
sans l'ombre d'un doute
elle aurait été du côté de miou
françoise cliquer oui elle aura été du
goût du côté de mitu c'est évident et
ceci dit il ya on ne peut pas faire
parler les morts comme vous dites mais
par contre il ya beaucoup de vivant qui
celui de vivante qui se réclament de la
morte
les essais difficiles oui c'est
difficile de les départager parce que
parmi celles qui ont été les plus
proches de simone de beauvoir les
positions actuelles sont absolument
opposé donc pas parmi le ce qu'on
pourrait appeler le premier cercle
autour de simone de beauvoir on va avoir
un tel un ski d'un côté on va avoir
christine delphy vraiment de l'autre et
je rappelle ce sont deux femmes que vous
aussi d'ailleurs vous avez côtoyé est
donc aujourd'hui elles sont aussi
profond sens absolument vue et du point
de vue théorique je dirais je pense
qu'il ya un
une évolution à partir de la pensée de
simone de beauvoir on ne naît pas femme
on le devient on le sait on a
l'impression que cette phrase là c'est
la totalité mais il faut interpréter les
choses et à partir de là il ya toute une
évolution théorique qui va ce qui ne
s'est pas mis tous qui est pas mis tous
et la pratique et dans la théorie on est
parti de là pourra pour faire le gender
et le cuir et est donc cette cette
filiation là se réclament de simone de
beauvoir moi je pense c'est ce que j'ai
écrit dans dernier article sur simone de
beauvoir
je pense que que simone de beauvoir
n'aurait pas été jusque là folle et pour
l'effacement des gens pour le dire de
manière se montrait elle n'aurait pas
été si elle dit si on n'avait pas de la
féminité on ne serait pas complètement
humaine il faut avoir on ne peut pas se
dissoudre
totalement voilà pourtant débat
évidemment qui est passionnant qu'on va
pas ouvrir là dans les dernières minutes
de l'émission est peut-être là-dessus
peggy sastre
effectivement c'est cette divine
lyon des féministes est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le vient de dire françois
speak voilà et est ce qu'elle a écrit
dans un article beauvoir n'aurait sans
doute pas été du côté des voix là du
combat gender ça me paraît assez
logiquement c'est ça je pense que de
pouvoir on peut on peut lui opposer une
phase en fait tu es dans ton fausse
route d'elisabeth badinter et qui lie
tous militantisme se heurte à une
difficulté qui est prendre en compte la
diversité de la réalité et ça c'est
quelque chose qui se qui se glissent
comme un lien qui correspond bien à la
pensée de beauvoir il reste qui reste
selon moi au total perd est justement
trop aveugle à la diversité et notamment
des femmes est ce que michel caillé
voilà comment est ce que vous révisé par
rapport à ce qui peut apparaître comme
un angle mort effectivement de la pensée
de beauvoir qui est peut-être un peu
trop
voilà qui prend tout d'un bloc le
féminisme d'un bloc là je suis quand
même très étonné parce que on peut au
contraire tirer des partis pris
philosophique 10 socialiste une toute
une toute une conception de la
singularité donc le ce n'est pas
effectivement la diversité aux sources
du relativise etc
mais c'est que au bout du compte la
véritable émancipation c'est lorsque
sera possible l'expression de lahesalu
larry tu es donc on va encore au delà si
je puis me permettre de la diversité
cette affaire terminée parce que en
préparant les missions je me suis livré
à un petit exercice j'ai cherché combien
il pouvait y avoir en france de lycée
simone de beauvoir y en a pas tant que
ça et j'ai été frappé aussi fait que
simone de beauvoir ne figure pas
systématiquement dans les programmes
voilà scolaire sur la philo ou la
littérature deux questions 1
comment est ce que vous expliquez ça et
deuxièmement est ce qu'il faudrait pas
qu'elle soit un peu plus enseignée
puisque je rappelle qu'on parle quand
même
selon michèle cahu d'un des auteurs d'un
des quatre livres de philosophie des
plus importants pour la france au 20ème
siècle à françoise picq pourquoi est-ce
que le nom de simone de beauvoir n'est
pas donnée de façon mais parce que je
pense qu'elle a gardée du moment où
elles écrivent deuxième sexe et de sa
participation féminisme des années 70
quand même une une image très très
contestataire trop subversive
subversives
avec en plus les positions qu'elle a
prises en dehors de ça si on pense au
manifeste des 121 contre la guerre
d'algérie
enfin elle à elle a quand même toujours
été bon alors maintenant on pense sartre
et beauvoir son sont font partie de
l'héritage commun mais il ya quand même
je pense toujours eu cette le fait qu'
il faisait partie enfin qu'ils ont été
des contestataires extrêmement important
et peu et que ben voilà on lit ce drame
et le séjour
voilà la vie est étonnant c'est que elle
a été beaucoup plus lus et certainement
étudié
notamment aux états unis il ya des
universités en tout cas des déchets
requis qui porte qui porte son nom
notamment de gender studies
donc ça c'est peut-être un contresens
mais en tout cas ça existe et là il ya
un retard un retard français donc c'est
ça qui est assez assez amusant que c'est
qu'elle a eu peut-être plus de vrais
lecteurs et lectrices aux états unis
qu'en france
peut-être que le mouvement ait débat va
revenir voilà comme ça va importer le
féminisme américain mais là en
l'occurrence et simone de beauvoir qui a
été exportée aux états unis merci
beaucoup il y aurait encore beaucoup à
dire sur sur simone de beauvoir sur ce
film que nous avons regardé ensemble
merci à tous les cas d'avoir participé à
cette émission en partenariat avec locks
et avec marie-claire quelques conseils
de lecture d'avoir votre livre françois
speak libération des femmes 40 ans de
mouvementée paru il ya une dizaine
d'années aux éditions dialogues on peut
aussi renvoyer à votre site françois ce
pic pourrait faire passer beaucoup de
documentation passionnante sur cette
question là
votre livre michel caillat simone de
beauvoir philosophe paru aux presses
universitaires de france je rappelle
également le titre de votre dernier
livre béquille sastre la haine
orpheline paru chez anne carrière et
puis un coup d'oeil à la une de l'ops de
la semaine on parle d'une autre femme
d'ailleurs de naomi klein l'intellectuel
de combat voilà enfin une autre figure
intellectuelle de notre temps merci
infiniment à chacun et à chacune d'entre
vous de nous avoir suivi et à très
bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]